alright thank you for that introduction
and my I'd like to give a special round
of thanks to the organizers of this
workshop they made some last-minute
arrangements to enable me to attend so
the reason for that is I have a four
week goes at home and so I was actually
watching a lot of the talks earlier this
week when when I wasn't here with him in
my arms and he really enjoyed them
actually so he actually laughed out loud
at a couple of the appropriate jokes and
this is also a plug for watching the
slot Simon's talks online they are just
fantastic so it might even be better
than being here because you can have
more comfortable chairs so it if you're
stuck at home it's not at all an
impediment to taking advantage of all
the talks that they offer here what
we're going to talk to you today is a
lot of the stuff or is a variation a lot
of the stuff that you guys have seen in
the rest of the workshop so we're going
to talk about graphic uses and what the
heck do I mean by a graph diffusion this
is not meant to introduce you to the
topic it's meant to introduce you to my
notation on the topic is it's slightly
different than a lot of what other
people have talked about um radicular
there's one sharp difference but what
what what we're really doing is we're
taking some type of graph structure here
and we have some some nodes that have
some information on them and we're
letting them sort of flow around the
graph or diffuse throughout the graph
and I don't want to be overly particular
about the type of diffusion because well
will will will look at one in particular
that that I'll define but really what
we're doing is we're looking at some
series of this form so a diffusion is an
expansion in powers of a transition
matrix P and so this is where the
difference comes in i define my
transition matrix to be column
stochastic so if you're used to
probability you will undoubtedly be used
to row stochastic transition matrices
because that's how they always do do it
do of them for whatever reason linear
algebra be like column vectors and so I
do column stochastic transition matrices
so i wish i had a mirror but i could put
up here to flip all of this stuff and
make it use
for the different size of the room to
see but it its columns to Catholic here
and so all of these diffusions have some
some notion of a seed that's starting
the diffusion so in that case this is
these two pin nodes here and these
things are used all over the place so
we'll see a couple of them but they're
used for attribute prediction there's a
problem called community detection
that's very common and applied data
where you want to take a graph and
divide it up into different groups that
have some type of meeting internally
it's used in ranking so Google's page
rank is a common example here one that
will see more about and then finding
small conductance sets oh so one other
thing I want to mention here all graphs
in this talk are going to be undirected
graphs so a lot of times these these
ideas are used with directed everything
i'm going to say just assume a connected
undirected graph it could have weights
however yes say that for simplicity are
you saying that good I'm thankful some
of the things won't work for directed
graphs okay so one one one specific
diffusion we're going to spend a while
looking at is the PageRank diffusion so
this is what google was made famous for
or what they fate fate famously used to
rank web pit pages it's since been used
in hundreds of other applications and
found to be a very successful way of
just spreading information around the
graph I'm calling these practical here
because they're they're ones that I at
least have references of the a lot of
different applications of where where
where where they're you so the PageRank
diffusion has had some expansion beta
and so you wait house of length K by a
value of beta to decay the nice thing
about this one and the feet kernels they
always converge and they converge
quickly so you only need you don't
really need to take these powers up to
infinity here you can truncate them at
some reasonable number say 10 50 100
maybe you don't need the full expansion
to get good at
see in practice so a lot of these
diffusions actually tie in with a lot of
other ideas that we're talked about
earlier in the week so you can interpret
them as sort of markov chains with some
type of hitting state or stopping state
there's a nice interpretation of page
rank in terms of that but it's not
really relevant for this talk what I
want to talk about here is a particular
type of localization at a lot of these
solutions have so if you take these
diffusions and run them on real-world
graphs you oftentimes see results like
this so here I've got a graph that's
approximately 800,000 nodes this is a
graph of the flickr social network and
what I've done is I've taken one note of
that graph and said where does
information from this one node diffuse
to the rest of the graph and so I solve
this linear system I just solved this in
MATLAB and then I plot the vector and so
when I plot this I get one two three
four maybe five six seven eight nine 10
11 12 13 maybe 14 I can't tell that's
the eighth or not there's only a few
large elements here if you just plot
this as a vector I generally don't like
looking at it this way though I like
looking at this picture instead which is
where I've taken this vector I've sorted
it and now I'm looking at the error I
get in an approximation by taking the
only the largest k entries here so if i
take 100 largest entries of this vector
and look at the error in an infinity
norm and a degree weighted infinity norm
then the hundred largest entries give me
an error approximately 10 to the minus 8
so all of the remaining entries of that
vector are below 10 20 minus 8 and lo
and behold I see that there's about 15
sort of significant entries of that
vector so there's this sharp drop-off
here where there's a big change in the
scores of these vectors and so these are
what we're going to call localized
vectors for this talk what we're going
to do is try and exploit them for a
couple of different
purposes for our missions understand how
localization these vectors can help make
some of these diffusions robust to graph
constructions and label mistakes and
actually make things faster too so you
sort of get to have your cake and eat it
as well all right now if you've seen
they give another talk there is a
different notion of localization I've
talked about in the past and so I wanted
to distinguish what I'm talking about
here from that other notion I don't know
if it's a better name for this but I
just called a uniform or strong which is
where you're looking for a vector X that
approximates the true solution in
something like a 1 norm to an accuracy
of Epsilon this is a really strict
notion of localization you get a global
approximation from a small number of
entries what we're doing in this talk is
an entry wise version so and it's
actually degree weighted so the degree
waiting makes a lot of the proofs and
the runtime results much much much much
easier to do we're not we're not going
to get into a ton of those here but it
turns out this devices for a lot of
results so that cuts in community so you
don't need a whole lot of accuracy in
these these vectors but this is a much
weaker notion of localization than that
a uniform notion so why should you keep
paying attention to my talk if you don't
if you aren't interested in any of this
stuff you're welcome to either exit or
fall asleep or work on your own talk or
some other paper I guess there's a stock
dead dead deadline coming up so I'm
going to talk about a new interpretation
for the PageRank diffusion in terms of
an approximation of a min cut problem so
we saw a talker earlier this morning
about how many cuts has to do with
conductance and add you can solve these
pair pair or parametric flow problems
there's a really neat construction that
shows exactly how you get this page rank
diffusion out of an being taught problem
there's also a really efficient
algorithm called the PageRank push
algorithm that gives you an
approximation to the PageRank diffusion
that gives you that entry wise
localization what we're going to show is
that that algorithm actually exactly
solves and when I say exactly I mean 16
digits of accuracy it solves a 1 norm
regularized version of the page rank
diffusion so if you like the output of
that algorithm you like the output of
that algorithm because it gives you this
really particular type of page rank
approximation what we're going to do is
we're going to use these two insights or
use these two as sort of primitives to
look at different types of diffusions
used in semi-supervised learning you
give a little bit of guidance on how you
can make them slightly more robust so
I'll explain I there's a statistical
notion of robustness and what I'm i
really mean here is robustness in the
sense of if you gave these to a somewhat
uninformed user and had them run them
we'll see cases where if you sort of
looked at the textbook algorithm you get
horribly wrong answers but there's like
a trivial tweak you can make to get much
much much much better answers and so
we'll go through a couple of those
alright so just a little bit of
background we're looking at page rank
here and undirected graphs a lot of
people think this is very very strange
so Markov chain on an undirected graph
has a unique station or sorry or uniform
random walk and an undirected graph has
this well-known stationary distribution
that's proportional to the degree of
every node however the page rank random
walk is a particular random walk with
probability beta we take one of those
standard random walk steps but then with
probability 1 minus beta we jump back
according to some seed distribution s
for this talk think of asses just a sink
a single node or just a few nodes
somewhere in naija graph these jumps
mean that your Markov chain is no longer
reversible so you no longer have a
simple trivial stationary distribution
of these PageRank random walks even on
an undirected graph and actually a great
open question would be a sort of
quantify the effect of this I've never
seen a good 12 quantification of how
much you can tweak the stationary
distribution with these random the jumps
empirically it's a lot unless actually
this is the stationary distribution of
your random walking which gives you
don't change anything but that's a sort
of Ted tag technical aside if you have
an undirected graph then you can either
compute the PageRank distribution X by
solving a linear system with the
transition matrix so ad in verse was the
transition matrix they were you can turn
it into a problem on the combinatorial
laplacian matrix so there was a talk by
ben you on monday talking about
different versions so it did different
regularized versions of spectral
clustering there they were adding
components to the laplacian matrix here
what we're doing is we're bulking up the
degree of the laplacian matrix so if
alpha were 0 here you end up with a
singular laplacian system but if you
just add a little bit of extra weight on
the diagonal you get a non-singular
system that's a good point up to a
degree schist a scaling of solving a
page rank system
yes so when you say jump when the way
from distribution is you're just simple
from the distance ample from the
distribution s and just update where you
are exactly and think of s is really
just one nodes that you sort of always
go back to where you started in the
graph okay I said it we relate this back
to admitting cut problems so this is a
review of the st min cup problem were
given a graph we're given to special
modes s and T well what what we want to
do is we fought is we want to find the
best way of splitting up this graph
where s is on one side and T is on the
other side that cuts the fewest number
of edges so you can State this as a
linear program with the incidence matrix
up the graph and what we're doing here
was writing it with the unweighted
incidence matrix and using the
capacities or the weights on it on on
the edges as a weighted norm so a lot of
people would have stuck the sea inside
that perform some sort of weighted
incidence matrix here the incidence
matrix is staying unweighted the weights
are going in the norms it's just a
notational thing that makes it a little
bit easier so this is really what we
mean by that notation this is a look at
your pro pro program if it were
unweighted you can solve this via
max-flow problem it's weighted you
either need a capacitated max flow
solver or you can just use a network
simplex solver or even just an
industrial LP package they tend to work
incredibly well and use these uh
problems
in order to relate pagerank two min cut
we're going to have to introduce a
construction that I've called the
localized cup graph it's related to a
construction use in a paper called the
that describes a primitive called flow
flow and proved by Reed Anderson Kevin
line from sota 2007 and more recently a
construction of islands are fo recchia
as you that was about localized flow
flow methods the idea is we're going to
take our original graph where you
introduce two new nodes SNT so standard
so far but we're going to connect node s
to all nodes in the subset s with weight
alpha times the degree of those nodes
and we're going to connect the vertex t
to all nodes in s bar with weight alpha
times their degree so in terms of page
rank think of s as giving you some
measure of that dis dis distribution
there
so this gives us a new incidence matrix
that now depends on s and so the st men
cut a problem here is just to minimize
this one norm objective subject to the
cut constraints there in order to get
paid rank we hit the world's simplest
slide transition we take this road
problem here and we turn it into an
electrical flow problem so we take that
one and make it into a tube so again if
you missed that we take the st men cut
problem and we take that one and make it
into it too so this so this is now a to
normal optimization problem or a
spectral optimization problem and if you
set up all the constants right the page
rank vector that satisfies that lip
linear equation is up to scaling by
about buying some some volume that
depends on the size of your set the
solution of this linear probe or service
cut convex optimization problem here so
again page rank is really just a
spectral relaxation of a particular st
min cut construction how you prove this
you despair square the objective apply
your constraints in its and it's easy
yes the two normal one so the min cut is
in the one warm so then you have to
relax to the electrical flow or the
spectral min cut but you take the
construction from the one warm and you
just approximate it with a to norman you
would have gotten page rank again this
is on this particular construction here
so it's not on a general one all right
so that worked for a very particular set
up that is i said there's a set s that
gives you that gives rise to a page rank
problem turns out the converse hold as
well so you can take any page or any
problem and construct the set s you just
need a slight generalization so when i
had our set s before you connected it
with weight degree leading to every node
if it was in that set and then it was
outside that set you had degree leading
to tea if you have a general vector just
the simplest cases the uniform form a
vector what you do is you connect every
node and s2 all nodes in your graph with
weight alpha you connect them to no tea
with degree minus 1 times alpha so the
idea here is that the total degree
you're adding to it to each note of the
graph has to be alpha so at every node
you're adding alpha 2 sorry alpha times
the degree of that node to its local
wait this is why you get the alpha d in
like the yellow flashing term okay so I
don't I hadn't ever seen it written this
as clean cleanly as this before what I'm
not sure this would have surprised
anyone who is really familiar with these
things although it is nice to have it
written out explicitly but PageRank is
really employed zits implicitly
approximating a solution of these a
steaming cup problems and at least now I
have a much better explanation for why
page rank shows up in all of these cuts
and foot and small small small
conductance problems when I have to
answer students about it but I claim
goes a couple of other insights we can
draw from this so this same idea holds
for a variety of other diffusions used
in semi-supervised learning as well so
let me just go through a couple of these
other constructions there was a paper by
Zhao at all in 2003 that described a
different technique with the laplacian
and what they're doing is they're taking
your seed set s and connecting it with
weight alpha 1 so they're not doing a
degree weighted version when you're
linking to your seed set but then
they're still waiting all connections to
a t such that the total weight you're
adding is alpha times D I call the page
rank 1 they get Anderson blank
instruction just because they were one
of the first ones to describe something
close there's others by the force to net
cord Cornell and some of the authors in
the room here where you ignore all the
intermediate nodes and just use
some additional label information and/or
explicitly pin the nodes to particular
sides of the set but again once you have
all of these flow problems you get a
spectral diffusion just by taking the
min cut problem and relaxing it 2 2 a 2
so a lot of what I'm going to say in the
second part i'll talk about in terms of
page rank but different very vey air or
variations on those same ideas apply to
a couple of these other ones as well so
what we're going to do now is study a
particular algorithm to compute an
approximation of the PageRank diffusion
very quickly this is what's called a
push algorithm for patron so the push
algorithm her page rank was before
proposed in the form that's most close
to what I have by Anderson Chun and
Liang in their 2005 stock stock paper
actually proposed even a variation of it
was proposed by Frank Frank McSherry je
me demande Papa Birkin and a couple of
different papers and actually it's
really just a special case of a linear
solver that goes back to Gauss so we'll
see that as well but why did they
propose it in the Anderson Xiang Liang
pip paper and what intent and what were
their customizations I'll describe the
shorter shortly but they were using it
to derive an improved runtime result for
some of these balanced solvers that
people look at but empirically it's been
used in a whole lot of different studies
of communities of networks so if you
want to do community detection on
networks this is actually one of the
most accurate methods of doing it and so
when I say accurate it shows up in study
after study after study is one of the
ones that gives you really good
communities in practice why is this this
is in some sense a great question but a
lot of studies this happens you can also
show a local cheater and a quality about
this particular out or you can use the
output of this algorithm to show a local
cheater and equality which relates the
set that you get back to the set of best
conductance that contains your seed
nodes a lot of people just use it
because they want some quick dirty and
cheap approximation to a pagerank vector
so in particular I would have no problem
running this
graph with four billion edges on my
laptop it doesn't need to explore the
majority of the graph in order to give
you this type of approximation to page
rank and so you can use on just massive
problems fit very quickly and the reason
it does that is it gives you these nice
weekly localized or entry by some
localized solutions of page rank so what
I'm doing here this will reset in a
second this algorithm depends on the
accuracy parameter epsilon and what I'm
showing you is how the solution of these
PageRank vectors these epsilon accurate
PageRank vectors vary with epsilon and
so what you can see here is it starts
from these seed nodes any node that
small is actually exactly zero in the
solution so the PageRank vector is in
general dense it's got a full side of
non-zeros but the output from this
algorithm only returns a very small
number for reasonable parameters epsilon
so it doesn't have to look at the entire
graph it's able to find these just by
doing some local exploration on the seed
the note and so you can see how as we
get more and more accurate answers it
has to fill in more and more the graph
how would you use us in practice what
you would do is probably do some type of
biceps and search where you're looking
four sets of something like a quarter of
the graph or a tenth of the graph so if
you find that it's becoming too dense
you'd reduce your value of epsilon down
and you and just stop that search there
so you can bound the amount of work it
does in terms of epsilon and this
parameter beta and PageRank so it gives
you an epsilon accurate solution this
entry was sent in 1 over epsilon times 1
over beta work the bush algorithm else
revenue second is closely related to the
gauss-seidel and GAO southwell methods
for solving a linear system of equations
for this slide we're going to look at
just a system of equations ax is equal
to B so a is any matrix here and be as
any right right hand side both of these
algorithms work in a coordinate wise
updating fashion so what they do is they
say pick a coordinate J of your solution
and update that coordinate J such that
you exactly solve the JS equation of
your
system okay so all they're doing is
they're picking a coordinate and just
being greedy I'm a coordinate saying hey
I can change X sub J so I'm going to
change X sub J to ensure that i satisfy
this so in words what your they're doing
is they're relaxing or freeing the Jade
coordinate and then exactly set and
satisfying the equation in that one how
do you choose the coordinate j well
gauss-seidel is it's usually explained
in a text book as you started equation
one and then you cycle all the way
through all the equations one down to j
and that's one iteration of Gauss I'd
devil and the entire matrix and then you
would repeat this over and over again so
you won through J 1 through J 1 through
J 1 through J now self was a little bit
smarter it says hey there's this notion
residual which says how much my
equations failed to be satisfied so the
residual is sort of how much error I
have or it's proportional to how much
error now South Pole says look at the
largest component of the residual and
update that equation so I make the
largest residual zero so note that after
i saw this exactly that J component of
the residual becomes zero so it's it's
sort of like squashing your residual all
over the graph and now every time you
squash it and one component that changes
else wearing your graph and so this is
in some sense the origin that they push
so you can use two different ideas to
implement these these things on the
graph which would be called pagerank
pushing pagerank pull respectively so
you could use page rank pull if you had
an undirected graph and you had access
to the in degrees which are really the
out degrees but in page rank pull what
you do is you'd say well hey the page
rank equation a switch to using alpha
here I apologize these were a series of
old animated slides and so I I didn't
want to muck up the animations just to
switch alpha to beta so I should be
writing beta here but I apologize i
think most people can get it what you're
doing is the page rank value what your
know depends on your
incoming ones and so all we do is we
just update that one to be the average
of our incoming neighbors and so this is
page rank poll which is satisfying that
equation locally in terms of that row of
of the page rank equation I said all
graphs are undirected if you did have a
directed graph sometimes it can be
annoying to access any degrees of that i
graph and so there's a way of rewriting
this which is called the page rank push
algorithm where you do do all the same
thing but you explicitly maintain a
residual vector so now when you update
the jet equation here what happens is I
add the component of the residual which
for page rank you can show exactly
cancels out my current term but then i
change this equation and so I change the
residual on all nodes that I linked to
so nodes X nodes a B and C have their
residual changed and so what happens is
i change my equation by adding the
residual I update my residual to be 0
but then I have to change all of my
neighbors residuals by some amount
that's proportional to how much I got
changed so this is the way it's usually
done in the PageRank push algorithm
because you maintain an explicit
solution vector and the residual vector
and using the residual vector sort of
allows you to see how far off you are in
this one you don't need a residual
vector so it saves memory on the
computer but it doesn't ever allow you
to sort of see where you might like to
operate on your vector so now there's
one more trick that makes it that makes
the push method work and this is in some
sense the key insight here so the push
method is it's used in Anderson's work
starts out with a solution at zero the
residual is just the right hand side of
the page rank system and we have a
duration one so while any component of
residual is a larger than epsilon so
that is well we're at least epsilon away
times the degree what we're going to do
is we're going to change that component
but we're not going to take
stuff that makes that component of the
residual exactly zero we're going to
take a step that makes the residual
exactly equal to epsilon times D or in
general there's a parameter row we get
that says how much you're going to be
between epsilon D and zero so if Rho
were zero then you take the step that
makes or that that's exactly equal to r
j if row is 1 then you exactly satisfy
that constraint there and then you
update the remaining residual for all
adjacent nodes and you leave everything
else untouched and that's the push
method so the key insight here is one
you only have to operate on entries that
are large and up and you can maintain
those in the queue so you don't have to
maintain any very expensive data
structures here the second thing is that
you step 2 or you take in some sense the
smallest step possible that will allow
you to stop considering this method or
that note again in the future and then
you just keep working through it okay
now here's the magic if you run that
algorithm you exactly solve this convex
optimization problem here so how does
this relate back to the min cut version
we saw before so the sea and the two
here are the same so this is again the I
think i mighta pet X before it turns out
you have to square the objective when
you look when when when you look at it
this way in the other case you could
have squared or 1 squared the objective
that was fine here you need the square
there and the objective the impact of
that parameter epsilon gives you a
number kappa here so oh sorry shift
change from epsilon 2 tau so tau and
epson are the same on the previous
slides so epsilon was the accuracy and
epsilon is equal to a towel so this
parameter kappa kappa or how much you
regularize or how much you approximate
the solution gives you how much of a one
more
see there is on your answer and then you
have the same types of constraints here
so this is really cool because it sort
of explains why the heck the answers
from this thing are sparse for
approximate solutions at page rank
there's no guarantee that they should be
sparse at all this entire solution is
dense there are a whole host of epsilon
accurate answers out there too would too
to a set of page rank linear equations
what's the sets that the push method
gives you that's been so useful in
practice well it's exactly related to
this one norm optimization problem and
it's sort of redundant to say now but in
general if you have a 1 norm it tends to
encourage sparsity so I'm not making a
precise statement about it here just
sort of rub relying on that but the
algorithmic complexity then gives you
sparsity explicitly so so this explains
amongst all the epsilon approximate
vectors why this method or why this
algorithm finds these sparse ones which
is really nice because you can do what
do I the same type of regularization on
the other method I on the other
diffusions as well and you can probably
make them a little bit faster and
practice which is one of the key
chanchal challenges with using them in
practice how do you prove something like
this you write out the KKT conditions
and then sit and stare at them in a
coffee shop for a very long time and
then come back the next day and then the
next day and then after a while you say
oh my gosh that's so simple how did I
miss that so again once you write it
down it's it's it's that there is
nothing left to I do but I don't know
how to tell you to come up without a
beat staring at it for a very long time
but this is really cool so the page rank
push method implicitly solves a 1 norm
regularized to norm cut approximation
but more importantly when we're solving
page rank push we had this tolerance
parameter epsilon and so when resolving
page rank pushed it as a really crappy
solution it's not a good approximation
of page rank but it gives us a perfectly
accurate answer to this other
problem so if you say these
approximations for community detection
are really good now you can look at this
other problem and look at better
algorithms to approximate it instead of
different types of approximations of
page rank in the first place and there's
actually yet another insight which is
that these regularize diffusions should
in some sense be more robust in data
applications and so this is the starting
point for the third piece of the talk
they're definitely faster Qi compute
these push algorithms run really thick
labor as computing entire page rank
vectors tends to be quite a bit more
slow so again all we're doing here is
just adding a one going written
regularization term on to these two
Norton diffusions so to study that we're
going to look at semi-supervised de and
or diffusion based learning and so the
idea here is we're given a graph we're
giving some set of labels on the
different nodes of this craft so here
the the canonical example this is the
digits data set so you've got a graph
between all the digits and you know that
this note here is a 1 this nodes of two
modes of 3 and 4 and the problem is to
figure out what the other nodes of this
graph are in terms of the digits and so
there's a whole bunch of different
algorithms for this but there was that
those those four we talked about
initially all based on diffusion where
what you do is you run a diffusion for
each label so you say I want to run a
diffusion for label one this gives me
some information over the entire graph
related to a node one
central able to give me some information
and then you assign labels based on the
results of those diffusions so we did
this and we cooked up a really simple
graph here so here is a graph with three
different classes so last one two and
three last two is a little bit smaller
and what we did is we took two standard
diffusion so today in the Anderson lang
there's actually a couple more pictures
off here that look the same but if I got
them all on the slide no one could read
it so trust me when I say they look the
same if you don't believe me I'm happy
to show you afterwards when you look at
these with three labels things looked
pretty good so for class 1 the diffusion
you get is this blue vector here and how
should you read this well the blue
vector I were looking at the weight on
every note of the graph and they're
ordered by their different classes and
so you see the blue vector is high on
class 1 and low on class 2 and 3 the red
vector is high in class 3 and low in
class 2 and 1 when you try this with the
Anderson lang you notice something
strange if you run this diffusion you
predict you see that class 1 is high
everywhere class 3 is lower than class 1
and class 2 is lower than class one
except for those single notes that you
chose is your seeds of your diffusion so
you say well maybe we need more classes
or something like this if you do jail
with 15 labels you see basically the
same thing the diffusion for class 10
dominates and you see the same thing
with Anderson Lang diffusion for class 1
continues to da da da dun Homme innate
now this is when as experienced people
with these diffusions you guys would say
well of course this is what happens
class one is bigger so when you sample
more you're just increasing the value of
that that the fusion there but what you
would do if you just follow the standard
algorithm and all the papers is you
would take these results here and
predict class 1 as the label for all of
these different cases
that's ridiculous so if you just
implement the standard algorithm without
an understanding these diffusions you
would get the wrong answer and you might
say okay maybe you've constructed this
we did this on the digits problem and so
if you just use the standard algorithm
and you look at the error rate if you
look at the average number of training
cases per class so this is on the digits
data set this is with a couple of
different diffusions here the error rate
you get is 0 point 9 so what happens is
you're always predicting one class of
your data set so it's not just the stink
like it's not that particular data set
this actually shows up in a variety of
cases oh I'll come back to what these
two are in a second but this is what
happens so these two sorry I'll say it
now these two lines are what you get if
you regularize your diffusions so if you
add that one or regularization and you
actually get much better answers here
and initially when we saw this we were
misled into thinking our regularization
actually helped things it turns out
we're both looking at the a problem
wrong so how much time do I have okay
good subsets the title of this seminar
is unifying theory in practice and I
claim that we made a very fundamental
error when we were attempting to look at
those values of distant the diffusion or
you'll do other class labels so remember
insight one diffusions are all
approximations to cut alright so when we
approximate a cut or when we approximate
an eigenvector how do we take that
eigenvector and round it back to actual
cut of our graph well there's the
standard algorithm which says you take
the zero splitting of that but that's
not a very good algorithm in practice
and in fact the chiar in a quality
doesn't apply to that cut the cheater
inequality applies to I the sweep cut
where you go through all partitions
induced by the order and so the way to
fix this is really simple if you look at
this that this our result here for
Anderson laying with 333 labels if you
just look at the ordering induced by
these three vectors
you'll get the album you'll get the
answer right in almost all cases so from
a last two although the value of the
class to diffusion is smaller than the
class one diffusion this note is the
second highest in the rank of the class
2 to diffusion whereas it's well below
all of these others in the class 1
diffusion and so the idea is you just
use the rank of these entries in the
vector sum of their value in order to
round so what happens so in other words
we sweep over all cuts from these
approximate ones but we just use the
rank of the vector and sorted entry
instead so when you do this on digits
here's what you get with the sort of
off-the-shelf text book out owl
algorithm which gives you disastrously
bad results if you just do rank rounding
you get exactly what you expect so first
of all you get nice era that decreases
as you add more class as as you add more
more out labels somewhat to our chagrin
it turns out that regularization has
almost no impact on this anymore so
whether or not you regularize you would
be doing that purely for speed and not
for any type of improved plummets which
is what we we were hoping for a little
bit there so the only difference between
these two is how you round the label so
this one's based on rank and that one's
based on value yes so I was wondering if
you could go back to the previous slide
I was wondering what if like I treat the
three things not as look don't look at
their right but just treat them as three
coordinates in my three special back
there mm-hmm I just posturing there
that's nice about your class ring type
of saying we'd not work so the problem
is how do you take admit so so you're
you're saying ignore the fact that we
sort of picked these with our label
points just cluster them right thing so
I guess each each vertical you know
column is for one original data yeah now
if I treat three the value of color
a little more tonight right represent my
point in your space so you but but then
how do you turn that into a label rush
so you do regression on the labels so
now I remember thinking about this and
had some good example for why that
doesn't help you in this case and now
it's failing me so that's an excellent
question let me think about it again and
try and remember that so let's talk
after the talk and I convinced myself
that that didn't have so suffice it to
uh say I still think that rank base
rounding is a much simpler thing that
you can do here that just totally fixes
the problem but there's one other point
I wanted to make in the five minutes I
have left when you do so what I mean by
rank is this is the node with ranked one
in diffusion one this is the I think
this is ranked to this is ranked three
four five six so just list them by their
orders and then take the nodes with so
so now now now we have a new set of
information which is the order of every
note in the diffusion and say oh I want
to find the diffusion where it's the
highest ranked and so the highest value
but how do you decide you have three
different rankings I so which ones we
don't do it so this one this uh note
here is ranked 2 in class 2 and it's
ranked 52 in class one and probably
ranked 23 or something in class 3 so I
choose the maximum of those so in in
matlab this is almost embarrassingly
simple you just call sort on the vector
and then you call max so instead of call
it calling max initially you call sort
first and then call max yes yeah so yeah
so yeah I guess air percent just you
have a sense of whether the air is
larger and like the large classes where
else distributor that's an excellent
question i wish i had a statistic off
the top of my head but no no i don't um
when when we looked at the digits I mean
you do see that its largest in the
largest class so it always predicts that
class and just gets everything else
wrong so the intuition that it's it's
worse than the largest classes is right
so if you knew the class sizes up front
you would probably normalize things in a
way that that avoids this but you don't
have to do that you can just use the
rank instead so our point here is that
if you were packaging this up you would
probably want to use rank instead of the
value and all of these other ideas
because it will give you something
that's pretty much as close but it's
just a lot simpler
you know I cheated when I was explaining
and semi-supervised learning I said that
we're given a graph and this is not true
we're going to date usually in a
semi-supervised learning problem with a
few labeled points and we want to
predict the label most of the data and
so step zero of this algorithms actually
create a graph from our set of points
and so when we do this time you
supervised learning on graphs what we
usually do is use some type of distance
function between nodes and there's a
parameter here which is a variance / / /
or a kernel width / renders the right
way of thinking about it so if you know
the answers or if you have some time to
use them some experimentation you can
cross validate over these but what we
want to understand is is it sparse
graphs or dense graphs where these
things matter more so in some sense
people like sparse graphs because
they're easier to work with but are
those the best things that you can do in
terms of the data so we wanted to see
where does this regularization in terms
of the one norm term on page rank
actually help warrants it help more with
dense graphs or sparse graphs all right
do we have time for a quick poll can I
just see what people think it will help
more with sparse graphs or dense graphs
smart sprouts okay dense graphs okay I
thought it would help more with dense
graphs and I was totally wrong it helps
more of a sparse graphs and so we did
did did some additional study to to
investigate why so what we're looking at
here is how much regularization matters
for a wide Colonel width or a dense
dense graph and it doesn't matter at all
if your graph is dense this is just like
a non-issue if your graph is sparse it
actually does improve your performance a
little bit just a little bit so I don't
want to make too much of a deal about
these I was really sort of shocked about
those I wanted to understand it a little
bit more Oh
so excellent questions so do you need to
penalize more and the answer is no so if
you penalize a dense graph more what
happens is you get worse results and and
and I'll give a little bit of intuition
for this we're trying to pin some of
these things down in theory we don't
have the statements nailed down yet but
intuitively if you regularize too much
you regularize their entire solution
away so there's some natural notion of
regularization that gives you the right
answer and if you're below that you get
the wrong answer and if you're above
that it doesn't matter and with the
dense graph there's basically no room
there so you either get the right answer
or you get the wrong answer so what we
did is we took a really simple graph I
can draw here we have in some sense the
motivation here's these are the correct
answers we want I've introduced one
error and here I'm looking at the value
of a diffusion in this graph so these
are the answers I want to say are
correct these are what I want to say or
unavoidable errors so once you introduce
that additional wrong label you can't
avoid those errors if you have a
semi-supervised learning or you would
have to have another label allow you to
correct those errors but just from one
one label you can't avoid them so what
we want to do is take this graph and
make a dense so how did we do it just to
play around with this what we took the
sum of the cape hours of the graph so we
powered up the adjacency matrix and use
that as a dense representation of this
graph instead and it turns out we saw
exactly the same thing so up on the top
we have no regularization so these are
fully dense diffusions here we have the
sparse graph here we have the dense
graph here we add in regularization so
what happens on these two cases when you
run the diffusion the full diffusion in
the dense graph you can see it actually
does a pretty good job and all the
correct answers and it does a reasonable
job of actually correcting the incorrect
answers and if I have to hand wave in
two seconds and say why this is when you
densify the graph you reinforce the
manifolds
sure the underlying structure of the
graph when you look at this with
regularization there's almost no
difference between these two the fusions
anymore in all cases you sort of with
the regularization or on the sparse of
the dense case you down wait all of
these avoidable errors up in the upper
right and so that's hand wavy I know
this is unifying theory practice and my
last slide is we need some theory to
explain let's go go go go go beyond
their more completely but I think
there's a real phenomenon there so if
you want to do do these diffusions more
robustly in practice so first of all
encourage you to use rank based rounding
and two if you get actually can it seems
like denser graphs give you better
answers and practice will be the gaze up
desktop there's better to get in Kuwait
abuse that's an excellent conjecture up
you would know more about that that I
would off the top of my head so is does
anyone else know know about with denser
graphs a better cheek or inequalities
I don't know that either except
excellent question
so again if you'd like more so there's a
paper we had it icml that talks about
these relationship with page rank and
we're trying to tie tie up the odd not
on some of those diffusion based ideas
but that's it thank you today could you
do SH show the typo error again like
what was the lowest at diffusion gear so
the diffusion here is a spectral
diffusion so it's a pagerank diffusion
or a laplacian diffusion and the idea
what the avoidable errors is you want to
it doesn't show up quite quite as well
here but this diffusion here is actually
quite large in that region so if you do
the unregular eyes diffusion you
actually end up with large larger
entries than you would like out here now
ideally they are there going to be
corrected by a different one but if
they're not corrected enough that's a
regime where you would potentially run
into problems so again we're trying to
illustrate this this result that occurs
on the digits or it's not as easy to see
let's go go go go going on but I think
this motivates some so some some sort of
venues to tackle here so ideally you
want your diffusions to be 0 in this
region
thanks again